take it away Jay all right guys no Kelly
I'm going to ask you a series of
questions about Texas Oh God I get it
easy on her because you should probably
know all these wait what I don't live
there in a while okay you'll have what
you had to take in grade school every
kidding which I was super great take all
this all those tests is a history okay
only 45 seconds to get five correct
answers so 45 seconds five correct
answers okay if you're not sure you can
pass and come back to the question okay
but here's the catch before we get
started please put this Apple watch on
the watch is hooked up to my watch okay
if your heart rate monitoring her heart
rate your heart rate goes above 100 you
lose okay okay all right now and this is
a decibel counter all right if it goes
above 70 decibels which is like normal
conversation with normal people like us
if she goes above that you lose all
right you'll be branded the most
aggressive and deranged player and
Hollywood game night yes I am all right
okay and if you do win that title I
which means you've lost
okay would mean you make $1,000
contribution to Red Nose Day by name if
you win and you could I will make a
$1000 donation to Red Nose Day in your
name okay all right okay
so you accept this challenge I accept
your challenge though all right let's
get her up the clock up where's the
clock clock is right over here hey clock
are here okay and where am i car here
oh gosh okay like I've never done this
before go how many stars are there in
the Texas flag how many stars one there
very good very good and you stayed nice
and calm don't mess with Texas was
originally a message about what
littering oh it's great down down down
all right name two presidents who were
born in Texas born lyndon b johnson yes
yes yes Andy Johnson and George George W
Bush years born in Connecticut
Dwight thing well it doesn't matter I
stopped born toity yards in Eisenhower
which I didn't know name for nations
that have ruled over Texas or before
like Mexico like mix it like Mexico
Mexico I'm sorry but you did not succeed
and you swore I said shoot no no you
only got a few questions right Oh your
heartbeat went up to one hundred thirty
two dollars and you hit 99 decibels it
is official ladies and gentlemen she is
the most aggressive as arranged
[Applause]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel and
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going